Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Binaural or 2.5D audio means a sound recording
that provides the listener with an amazing
3D-ish sound sensation.
It produces a sound that feels highly realistic
when listened to through headphones, and therefore,
using a pair is highly recommended for this
episode.
It sounds way more immersive than regular
mono, or even stereo audio signals, but also
requires more expertise to produce, and is
therefore quite scarce on the internet.
Let’s listen to the difference together.
We have not only heard sound samples here,
but could also see the accompanying video
content which reveals the position of the
players and the composition of the scene in
which the recording is made.
This sounds like a perfect fit for an AI to
take piece of mono audio and use this additional
information to convert it to make it sound
binaural.
This project is exactly about that, where
a deep convolutional neural network is used
to look at both the video and the single-channel
audio content in our footage, and then, predict
what it would have sounded like were it recorded
as a binaural signal.
Let’s listen to a few results.
The fact that we can use the visual content
as well as the audio with this neural network,
interestingly, also enables us to separate
the sound of an instrument within the mix.
Let’s listen.
To validate the results, the authors both
used a quantitative, mathematical way of comparing
their results to the ground truth, and not
only that, but they also carried out two user
studies as well.
In the first one, the ground truth was shown
to the users and they were asked to judge,
which of the two techniques were better.
In this study, this new method performed better
than previous methods, and in the second setup,
users were asked to name the directions they
hear the different instrument sounds coming
from.
In this case, the new method outperformed
the previous techniques by a significant margin,
and if we keep progressing like this, we may
be at most a couple papers away from 2.5D
audio synthesis that sounds indistinguishable
from the real deal.
Looking forward to a future where we can enjoy
all kinds of video content with this kind
of immersion.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!